I'm just imagining a big bowl of
scrambled eggs with bourbon in it I've
seen eggnog in movies but I've never
seen it in real life I think it's
something that you drink at Christmas
when you want to get drunk and forget
about your family all I know is that
it's drunk during the festive season so
Christmas and like the weeks leading up
to it I can't tell if it's good or not
because when you see it in movies they
either love it or they really hate it we
don't really get a white Christmas in
Australia so this is probably the
closest thing that we can again I don't
think it's gonna be warm I can smell the
rum it kind of smells like a dirty egg
cup has been left in the dishwasher for
two weeks it actually looks like
dishwater - it sort of smells like
somebody's thrown up Christmas pudding
tis the season to be drunk my friends
mmm that's quite something that's good
yeah it's kind of like a glass of milk
with rum in it kind of burns going down
so I can see why it's a good light
winter Christmas drink I can already
feel it actually it's like warming me up
and making me feel a little bit happy
that tastes like um someone spiked
custard it has surprised me I can't
really taste the egg in it like I was
really worried it'd be like really eggy
it's tricky because Christmas falls in
summer in Australia and it does get
really hot so I can't see are stringing
something like this warm I think maybe
we should try eggnog on ice mmm that
would be good it'd be good for our
Christmas sometimes I feel sure yeah
bottoms up
yeah I could get around it maybe a
Christmas in July thing Americans know
how to do Christmas they absolutely
embrace it and they invented it exactly
an eggnog just another tick on the list
eggnog sounds like an insult that you'd
call someone like such an eggnog yeah
boy you're in the kind of your eggnog
exactly